anyhow let's put that aside and I'll
just wrap with a couple questions which
actually come from a friend of mine
who's watched so much of your work and
is a huge fan his name is Matthew Wyden
he asks Aquinas says that God is being
while Whitehead says God is becoming do
you think these are opposed or both
captured with platonism why did it is
wrong
being
has nothing to do with process
process ontology is why I had understood
it
so
my own
Outlook towards Whitehead is in the
sense mixed I owe him a great deal
because he opened my eyes to bifurcation
and the absolute
absurdity of our scientistic well done
song so we are totally in agreement on
that but I am a platonist right down to
the bone and Whitehead certainly is not
even though he is very sympathetic to
Plato and in fact in this book which I
read wrote where I read when I was 14 he
says that
all subsequent philosophy or footnotes
to Plato
so he was very respectful of platonism
but he was not actually in his
philosophy platonist
there's no way of squaring his process
theology with platonism and so I can
very well understand that
somebody who is a process theologist and
sort of following Whitehead in that
part of his teaching might have
reservations about
adamsky theorem
at the core of viveki's platonism is his
ontology which he calls the perceptual
promise that reality is inexhaustibly
intelligible he has a Taoist definition
of reality calling it The Ground of
being which itself cannot be a being but
is rather the unintelligible ground
which all being comes into being Western
religions rather consider reality to be
be Supreme Being an inexhaustible
sentience whereas Saint Maximus joined
these saying God is both being and
non-being what do you think about these
different ways of describing reality
well
I think Saint Maximus was basically
right
there is in Christianity the a tradition
let's see what is it called
it it corresponds
to
had writer vedanta in the sense that it
is very it it emphasizes the
Transcendence of God to an extreme
but there is also in Christianity a
tradition which is based upon the
imminence of God so God is both
absolutely Transcendent and absolutely
imminent whether we can grasp that or
not you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy